welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and Doctor Strange in the
Multiverse of Madness revealed an even
higher body count of Illuminati's killed
by the Scarlet Witch a never-before-seen
set video of Wanda having killed Balter
the brave confirming the rumors of
Daniel Craig blame the Asgardian
half-brother to Thor who's terrified of
mistletoe also confirming some official
storyboard concept art that we saw for
the film so in addition to confirming
Daniel Craig's involvement with this
movie this is also consistent with
reporting before the release that balder
would be among the Illuminati in that
part of this production actually
involved a stand-in for Michael
Fassbender Magneto which would mean that
Multiverse of Madness nearly had a
Scarlet Witch vs Magneto father-daughter
subplot that would have had all of us
asking way more questions about Evan
Peters Pietro from One Division who
remember in X-Men Days of Future Past
and X-Men apocalypse Explorer The
Father's son relationship with Magneto I
really got to do a full breakdown of the
movie Multiverse of Madness almost was I
mean I definitely need to do a full
breakdown of the movie Thor 11 Thunder
should have been because what the [ __ ]
happened there maybe these will be
projects that it really take some time
researching on new Rockstar's new
spin-off Channel The Deep dive which is
launching February 17th go ahead and
pre-subscribe I'll still be here on new
rockstars but once or twice a week over
there I will be really going in depth
with some real meaty topics but in this
video I'm gonna break down everything we
know about Magneto and balder the brave
versus the Scarlet Witch and Multiverse
Madness so we're learning how the fox
X-Men movies are really being soft
adopted as pseudo Canon by Marvel
Studios Hugh Jackman Wolverine of course
coming into the MCU in Deadpool 3 and it
sounds like using a timeline plot device
borrowed from the time variants
Authority in Loki and of course there
was Patrick Stewart Charles Xavier
quoting his line for X-Men Days of
Future Past two doctor strange and
Multiverse Madness just because someone
stumbles and loses their way doesn't
mean they're lost forever just because
someone stumbles loses their way
it doesn't mean they're lost forever
most recently a teaser video for Disney
Plus's Stan Lee documentary showed
Stan's many Marvel cameos but the one
they opened with was a close-up of stand
sunglasses as he watched icbms rock it
up into the sky which is a shot from its
cameo in 2016's X-Men apocalypse with
his wife Joan ooh by the way voiced
Madam Webb and Spider-Man the Animated
Series this is the scene when Michael
Fassbender Magneto helped apocalypse
threaten the whole planet by activating
the nuclear arsenals of the United
States and the Soviet Union but rather
than blowing up these countries he just
sent all the nukes into space all this
is a way of saying I don't think Kevin
feige wants us to forget any of the fox
X-Men movies happened and he's
definitely not afraid to call back
characters and plot points it even lines
a dialogue directly from those films and
MCU titles going forward now this green
screen footage of dead Bulger the brave
comes from Insider who looked back at
2022 movies and got some exclusive set
footage including this shot of wander in
the Baxter Foundation lobby with balder
dead in the foreground this isn't
Elizabeth Olsen this is her stunt double
CC ice doing some impressive wire work
as she gets thrown back this is part of
the shot that they use for one is duel
with Captain Marvel Maria Rambo also
herself recorded all of her lines and
close-ups on a completely closed set
without any of the other members of the
Illuminati and a lot of times she had no
idea who she was sharing the scene with
she actually revealed this to Vanity
Fair after the movie came out do you
think this man is the smartest man alive
no
I don't know him though but I would
never assume that an actor would be the
smartest man alive
you don't know him at all
I don't think so no I've never met him
you were in the same movie
I've never met him
she's coming out truthful and balder the
brave we see in the foreground is
probably also a stand-in though it
sounds like Daniel Craig made it pretty
far through the casting process based on
an interview he did with Josh Horowitz
recently have you ever heard of the
character balder the brave
no there was a report Daniel that you
were going to be in Dr Strange
don't you hide behind that mug Daniel
Craig
foreign
[Laughter]
would it be interesting to be in a
Marvel movie I would take any job I'm
good I'm just like if the hours are good
I'd take any job how many of course
it's like
um sure absolutely yeah definitely okay
yeah
he's good he's too good for me damn it
um so it just sounds like this movie
cast a wide net and conceived a lot of
scenes with a lot of different
Illuminati Alternatives and then
narrowed down their options based on who
they were able to get through casting
Michael Waldron said that his first
draft of this sequence included Wanda
facing hope Van Dyne Wasp from the
Illuminati and then killing Hope by
clapping her hands together to smush her
and then this concept storyboard art
from Soren bent includes imagery of
nightmare as well as Iron Monger or
maybe the Hydra stomper skinny Steve
from what if and then a very mysterious
shot of Charles Xavier with an arrow
labeling him mantis which I think could
be a connection between his telepathic
and her empathic abilities but of all
these Fassbender Magneto would be the
most personal to Wanda of course as
someone implied to be her father from
Another Universe Not only would this
give a second life to Evan Peters to
still exist as Quicksilver from Another
Universe of the MCU Multiverse it would
also make wanted killing Magneto even
more devastating actually if you
re-watch Wanda killing Charles Xavier
the final version of the movie has her
doing this in a white void Charles's
mental projection but some other concept
art from Alexandra mandragiev had the
scene in a different location a pile of
rubble that might have actually been the
actual Halls of the Illuminati with two
different wandas walking around now it's
still Charles in this art though he's
wearing his Green Jacket instead of
switching to his 60s black turtleneck
clearly the creative team toyed with
various versions of this in the final
version of the movie Wanted killing
Charles it's completely separated out
from her killings of the other members
of the Illuminati because Charles is
really the one we have the most
attachment to he's the one we feel worst
about but I think originally this story
beat could have had her father not the
616 Scarlet Witch's father but
specifically eight three eight hijacked
Wanda's bothered from that Universe I
confessbrander Magneto appealing to
Wanda as a father to a daughter not
knowing what's wrong with her and then
Wanda slaughtering him without remorse
but instead of snapping his neck or
ripping his face in half as she did to
Charles maybe giving Magneto the
treatment he gave Sebastian Shaw in
X-Men first Class Wanda lifty Magneto's
helmet off and slowly ramming a Nazi
coin through his skull however this
fight went down the idea that Fassbender
Magneto might have been
lens Credence to my theory that the a38
universe is actually the same universe
as the Box X-Men Universe in that
morning Charles Xavier will be all the
other Fox X-Men characters hey by the
way if you see me on the channel a
little less this week it's because I'm
on my honeymoon for the first two weeks
of January and we'll be back soon but
enjoy all the great content being made
by the rest of the new rockstars team
and be sure to subscribe to new
Rockstar's new channel the Deep dive
launching February 17th Channel handle
and on all socials at Deep dive NR you
can follow me on Instagram and Twitter
at EA boss followed you rockstars And
subscribe to new rockstars for more
breakdowns and theories of everything
you love thanks for watching bye
[Music]
thank you